[Music]
on today's show we talk about anxiety
and what do you do when your body's
anxiety alarms set off both in the short
term
and in the long term and we talked to a
guy who got laid off from his job he got
fired and he feels shame
and frustration and we have conversation
with starters and more stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney's show where we talk about
your mental health your relationships
your families your friends your
boundaries your workplace
everything anything we got you
so glad that you're here if you want to
be on this show never hesitate man give
me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
leave a message let me know what's going
on not me i'm not gonna listen to it but
kelly will
and then she will call you back and we
will set up a time for you to be on the
show
so excited for the folks who want to be
on there we're getting calls from all
over the planet it's so rad
and if you are not a telephone kind of
person go to johndaloney.com
ask ask and fill out the form
and we will be in touch with you cannot
wait
hey we have a new segment i'm going to
debut on this show
it's called why i love james childs
and i'm going to do it in poem form
james o james i love your curly hair
james oh james i'm the benefactor of
your care
that's the end of my poem is that good
i mean it was no shakespeare but i
really appreciated it wow
that was kind of a knife to my heart but
whatever see that was poetic
knife to oh ooh you're right include
some more emo lyrics like that and
i'll get on board james or james
as i sit in the shadows writing said
poems
what rhymes with poems
um ah james
oh james i said i sit in the shadow
writing lyrics i come to work
sad but you lift me with your gentle
spirit is that good
that was wonderful better than
shakespeare
at least on par with shakespeare
that concludes the new segment of i'm
grateful for
james i think it's a hit i think it's
gonna catch on that one's got some legs
that one's got some legs next week we
will debut
the next news segment why we're grateful
for kelly i need a week to
write this one out it's going to take
some a little more thought
and uh off to seek some expertise and
guidance
i'm so happy to be in this job
all right let's go to john in stafford
arizona what's up brother john how are
you
doing
doing good how are you dr dalony we're
rocking on man to break a dawn
what's up dude how can i help so
i read your book redefining anxiety and
i really liked it there's a lot of
really good stuff in there
thanks man the question i have though
is about you talk about your body's
warning signals
throughout the book and i
personally have a hard time turning off
those signals
oh very cool man i do
pretty good at talking myself through
situations and
understanding when anxiety hits but
even when i like sometimes when i
resolve a problem
and i forget about the problem i still
feel that anxiety
in me and i still feel like something's
wrong like my body's in danger
yeah dude good for you man so number one
thanks for reading the book and number
two
man you are in it now so you're thinking
through
so your body takes off on you or you
find yourself in a situation
um to beat the metaphor to death you're
identifying these alarms
are you able to to look at your overall
ecosystem and say
oh here's what those alarms are trying
to tell me
uh most of the time yeah okay so give me
a couple of examples of things you found
um the one that comes to mind the most
when i think about it is if i get
something wrong at work or something
my boss will come and tell me about it
and he's like a saint about it
he always is talking to me well moving
forward we're going to do this better
and
he's sure to tell me like i'm okay and
everything
but it's still like even when that
resolves and i
know that everything's okay i still it
just
lingers there with me throughout the day
all right so that is a great example
dude
um just for my own curiosity
has anyone told you shown you
in your past that that you suck
um i mean yeah
um did your mom dad brother sister
remind you on none none of them they
were good
no i i was bullied in elementary school
quite a bit okay so here's
and again we you and i could probably
talk for a couple of hours on
the trajectory in the history there um
here's a cool thing to note about your
body okay so your boss comes in and says
hey you didn't do this right
and for a hundred reasons whether it's
stories you're born into whether it's
stories you've told yourself whether
it's stories that people and all the way
back as elementary school were telling
you about your value you're a loser
you're an idiot you always screw this up
whatever those stories are
your body detects a threat it sees a
bear at the front of the cave where
you're living
and it has an old operating system man
it's got
fight it or run away from it
and that's about it it can if he doesn't
realizes i can't fight it i can't run
away from it i'll just
go to neutral i'll shut this thing off
right i'll shut the system down you may
have heard that called freeze right
but your boss can come look in the eye
and say man i love you i'm so glad you
work here
your boss can come tell you hey you
screwed this one up man with a smile on
his face but we got to get this one
better next time i need you to step up
and do this right
at that point your body has gone into
fight or flight because it's got a
history it remembers this story when
somebody come up and told you you are
not of value
right you don't have worth and then he
looks at you and says hey
you're on my team i love you i'm so glad
you're here and now we're on to the next
thing
your body still has to deal with the
cortisol and the adrenaline
and the heart rate right your body is
taking off on you
and what we don't have a good system in
modern
or modern world is what to do with that
does that make sense
right it's just there so there's a
couple of things i want to give you
to back out of this so we're going to
approach this two ways number one what
do you do when your body's just
detects a threat even though there's no
threat in in
your vicinity right so we can deal with
that
the other thing i want to do is begin to
teach my body
what is a threat and what's not does
that make sense we're gonna just reteach
it
it's we're gonna it's gonna it's gonna
literally grow new synapses and new
brain connections
in in my head does that make sense
so what we wanna do is turn off a lot of
the signaling
stuff so here's a couple of ideas i'm
gonna rattle these off just for the sake
of time
and you can keep this
um this call keep it in your library man
and we will
link to the stuff in the show notes and
um but i want you to write this stuff
down eventually and keep it as a
playbook for yourself
okay so will you work with me for 30
days on this will you give yourself 30
days 60 days to to start
re-connecting some new teaching your
body new things
yeah okay awesome so number one
no monster drinks or red bulls or
anything like that
is that cool already done all right
great are you a coffee guy
no so you're like a no caffeine dude no
cokes anything like that
i have my dr pepper every once in a
while but that's about it
okay you get two of those for the next
30 days how about that okay
okay all right the second thing is is
tell me about your friend's community
you have any folks that you connect with
on a regular basis
um there's my wife and her family
they don't care yeah
uh i'm just my friends at work and i
have a couple of friends that
i talk to every once in a while all
right so new responsibility
checklist number so number one you're
gonna cut out the stimulant stuff right
we are working towards this so um
i have folks who for years my students
would come and be like man i'm so
anxious all the time
i only had seven red bulls and four
monster energy drinks today
well it's like dude you're not you're
your heart is beating a thousand
so we're getting rid of that stuff we're
gonna really
dial back sugar consumption candy
junk food just stuff we're ripping out
of packages and just shoving in our face
okay
we're gonna give our body a good system
to work with
the second thing is we are going to
double down on relationships so your job
is to get with a couple of guys and go
do a thing once a week
at minimum and that can be going to an
arcade that can be going to a bar that
can be i don't care what y'all do
but i want you to go get with a couple
of guys and it's going to be awkward
it's going to be weird
and you don't have to have any agenda or
anything like that y'all just go hang
out
okay that could be asking people at work
that you trust like hey let's just go
hang out we're going to go to a movie
we're gonna go whatever concert whatever
i don't care what it is but y'all gotta
go do something go bowling
go do something okay um the third thing
do you ever
exercise work out or anything like that
um not a whole lot my work is pretty
labor intensive but not anything more
than that
okay so starting today you've got some
sort of movement practice
that's gonna also if you can be outside
okay so if you work a really
labor-intensive job if you're slinging
boxes all day
then i want you to make sure in the
mornings you go for a walk
in the evenings after dinner as a
postprandial glucose
i want you to go for a long walk and you
can i'd love you to take your wife with
you on this one or your dog
and i want you all to go for a long walk
together and i want you to go slow
and i want you to breathe deep and what
we're doing here man is we are cycling
that
we are cycling that excess energy out of
our bodies okay
that pent up ah that's all there we're
letting it roll
okay the next thing i want you to do do
you keep any sort of gratitude journal
at all
um not written down now you do know
starting today before bed i want you to
get on your way home from work i want
you to stop at like walgreens or walmart
or something 99 cents pick up a spiral
notebook
um and i want you to write at the top of
it gratitude journal and i want you to
write five things before you go to bed
that start with the words i am grateful
for and i don't care what you put in
there
i'm grateful for mine this morning i i
i'm working on a book so i was up late
so
i got i looked at my sleep tracker and
had like four hours of sleep last night
my first thing was i'm grateful for my
air-conditioned house it's hot in
nashville
and that way i grateful for my air
conditioning i was grateful for my kids
and my wife i was grateful for
my faith community and my friend right
so whatever it is
at night five things and since you're
working on your body i want you to do it
in the morning too so the first thing
you do when you wake up
i'm grateful for at night i am grateful
for
five things okay you got it okay
now here's the next most important thing
i want you to have another spiral
and when your body takes off on you
i want you to use language that is third
person
and i want you to be curious have fun
with this and i know that sounds
nuts and listen i've been doubled over
insane with anxiety so i get what i'm
saying sounds bananas
but i want you to be
intentional about being curious and have
fun and i want you to ask this question
john what's your body doing
and i want you to write down your
answers what is it protecting you from
in that tone of voice okay and i don't
want you to say what is
my what am i trying to there's actually
different brain circuits when you say
the words
i my there is a
i'm in it there's a set of brain
circuits when you are
distant from it there's a different set
of brain circuits that work on that
problem
it's why somebody can come up to you and
say hey man i'm really feeling anxious
and you
john can rattle off five or six things
they need to go do but when you're
feeling anxious
it locks down on you right or when
somebody asks you hey what's the way
my wife could you give all that kind of
answers but then when your wife does it
you're like
i don't know i don't know i don't know
because one of those circuits is when
you're in it and those others when
you're distant from it
it's a great book uh by eric crop i
think called chatter
um it's a quick book but it was
excellent about talking about the
how to distance yourself so i want you
to write down hey john what's your body
trying to tell you what is it scared of
right now
it's probably gonna come back to a story
you've told yourself for a long time
that you're a loser that you're gonna
screw something up
that everyone doesn't like you that
you're a failure
that you're always an idiot and it's
probably gonna come back to bullying in
high school it's gonna come back to some
coach it's gonna come back to a mom or a
dad
who should have told you they loved you
and they didn't whatever that looks like
but that's how you're gonna begin to
unwind those stories what's my body
trying to tell me
hey john what's your body trying to tell
you right now oh that
i'm gonna get fired and then the final
thing is i want you
to demand evidence from those things
okay
i just want you to ask hey john is that
true
then you can go no it's not true john he
told you
i love having you on this team right i
love having you on this team
so grateful for that you're here but hey
we can't throw boxes like that we gotta
do it like this next time
love being married to you man but man
will you please take the trash out
every alarm goes off ah she's gonna
leave ah she's just nagging oh [ __ ]
oh hey john what is your body trying to
tell you oh that i failed my wife is
that true
no it's not i need to take trash out or
i'm failing my wife
yeah i need to take the trash right
whatever it is but get some distance
from it and write it
down and one last thing grab while
you're at walgreens grab a package of
note cards
and just write out your morning whenever
you're about to leave for work here's
what i got to do today
keep a small note card with you just put
in your pocket you can go spend a
thousand dollars one of those planners
with like 500 ribbons in it
enough with the ribbon planners people
you can go get one of those or you can
just get a note card that's what i use
i got two in my pocket right now because
i didn't finish everything from
yesterday
and so um get a note card and that's
control
right so going back to connection safety
and control and then you're just gonna
start pulling apart those stories man
but you my brother are on the right
track those are a few
simple things you can do if you feel
your body spin out on you once you're in
a
your boss is laughter go outside and go
for a walk for a minute in the sunshine
go for a walk
if you can if you want to be a nerd
about it take your shoes off and walk in
the grass
um i was doing that the other day here
at the office and somebody took a
picture of me
and several people took pictures of me
and they're like hey you look like a
weirdo
um but i'll go walk in the grass
barefoot right and there's
a whole other podcast but um and breathe
through it
and just be curious what are you trying
to protect me from right now
and there's something about not fighting
letting your body know we're not
fighting we're not running
what are you doing often your body will
go oh
oh you're in control okay cool and it
will stop that system
and then you got to discharge the
cortisol the internal those chemicals
all that energy that's been fired up in
there
right we're running on old operating
systems and then of course sleep man you
know all that stuff sleep and
supplements and
partridge in a pear tree that's another
thing that's enough to keep you busy
after 30 days i want you to write me
back call me back and you can call that
dude and say that
all that stuff was stupid none of that
worked it will
but call me back call me back all right
we're going to take a quick break we'll
be right back on the dr john delaney
show
[Music]
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one
i've got a solution i've partnered with
better help
for customized online therapy for you
video chat phone or even text chat
counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you
become a better version of yourself help
you
get on the road to being well go to
betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
all right let's go to fayetteville
arkansas we're going to talk to another
john
but with no h what's up john with no h
hey dr john i appreciate you taking the
time to listen to me a little bit man i
appreciate you brother what's up how can
i help
man well i got i ended up getting fired
from my job in february
and i actually have a i had a two-year
contract so i'm getting paid
through march of next year but i'm just
struggling because
i thought i had another job in place i
haven't been able to find anything and
just trying to figure out where to go
from here
i mean they pay me good money there's no
financial need it's just
trying to find myself and find a use
because my my job has always kind of
been
who i am and i've struggled with that
and pretty self-aware of it but
yeah i'm just kind of having a hard time
with it sucks man
what'd you get fired for you know it was
actually because i was being
pursued and interviewed for other jobs
and didn't end up getting them but
thought there was a lack of loyalty and
went a different direction was there a
lack of loyalty
you know i i don't think so because the
jobs i was interviewing for were
uh promotions with 50 pay raise
big time programs that kind of thing so
i'm a man i i've had
seasons when i had hundreds of employees
okay
um anytime somebody worked for me had an
opportunity to go do something big
go get promoted go man i think i was
i always tried to be their number one
cheerleader man sure right
so i'll tell you this you're lucky that
you're out of this mess
okay if somebody would rather cut your
knees out and say how dare you try to
progress your career how dare you try to
go make more money how dare you
man you don't want to work there anyway
right right now that doesn't help
the existential issue which is you got
fired and that sucks
right there's some data that talks about
getting fired is like the psychological
impact which means the physiological
and biological impact what does that
mean you're not a wimp
that means that your body has been
injured okay
similar to losing a loved one and when
we lose a loved one
we have a whole process for that we have
a funeral we dress up in different
clothes
we talk to our friends about it we mourn
it we have a drink we take some time
away
and when you get fired you just go try
to find another job
right right have you sat down and just
straight up
mourned this thing and grieved it you
know
probably not in that sense the first two
months afterwards i was
interviewing and looking for jobs and i
kind of
sat back and relaxed and said hey i'm
going to enjoy it i'm getting paid i've
got
two young kids at home i get to coach my
kids t-ball team for the first time but
i don't think i ever mourned it i've
tried to enjoy it and see the blessings
that i have in my life
but then after a couple days or a week
it goes back to the
embarrassment the shame there you go
that's it man so you ignored it you
tried to run from it and you hey
you ran from it towards good things man
coaching your kids t-ball team
being positive about it those are all
good things but you can't run from it
right okay what does the embarrassment
and shame come from
you know it's and i don't think she mean
like my wife i feel like i've lost
respect and
she always comes in we talk about it
we've got a great relationship but
i'll say hey that was disrespectful i
know i don't have a job right now but
i'm still
trying and she said well i didn't mean
it that way and all my friends are in
the same profession and
they're super successful and i i have
been and been doing great
but it's and they're the best it just
when you're around them and they're the
again the best friends in the world but
hey they're being
successful they're where i want to be
and now all of a sudden i'm not we're on
the level playing field now it's
hey i'm unemployed and can't get a job
when six months ago i was
turning turning down jobs that's right
that's right so you're in a season man
it's winter and it's cold outside right
yeah is it going to be this way forever
no and that that's and that's the hard
part is because
march is a long way away but it's close
it's just
they're hiring it's kind of a
interesting career but the hiring season
is in the winter
yeah and kind of waiting for that to
come back again so
here's what you need my man two things
number one you need a purpose you gotta
get out of bed every day
so i want you to go find just a job okay
go to a place where you can go do a
thing and it doesn't have to be your
dream job it doesn't have to be a
whatever but it's got to go be a thing
where you can contribute
and where you even if it's
i don't know if it's starbucks i don't
care what it is but you've got to go be
a part of something where you're
contributing
okay yeah and the second thing is i want
you to double down on some service
i want you to find some people that are
not in your house that you can go serve
whether it's go find two people on your
street and just mow the lawn
and do that regularly go find something
outside of yourself because right now
you're stuck
inside your head and you are starting to
tell yourself stories about other people
who love you
and what happens is this thing's going
to spin faster and faster and faster on
you
they're not going to want to be around
you because you're going to be hard to
be around
and then it's going to spin faster and
spin faster and then it's going to
become a self-fulfilling prophecy
right yes so man
i've had buddies who've lost jobs i love
them
that's hard you know what i mean it's
heartbreaking right and
here we're going to make fun of them
either way because they're my friends
right so if they start working at
starbucks be like oh
that's part of it right i want you to
put your head
high you got fire dude own it
yeah right i think your wife still loves
you she still loves you
yep yeah dude she still loves you that's
awesome and
does uh your kids still love you
absolutely yeah man
and so have a funeral for this thing
probably take your wife out and let's do
this thing right
let's have a funeral for it i want you
to be open about like
i feel like a failure i feel like a
loser and i'm gonna put these feelings
to bed today i'm gonna acknowledge i
liked this job
i wish i hadn't gotten fired from it um
i was a good employee and they let me go
and
uh and then we're gonna have a proper
funeral for this thing and then you're
gonna get up you're gonna go find a job
and dude if somebody won't hire you
because you had interim work
then you don't want to work there either
i would love for somebody to have a
paycheck for a year and they're like man
i just went and ground one out i just
went over there to starbucks i went over
there to my neighbor's firm i went to
work for one of my buddies
doing three levels below what i normally
do just to have a
have a job to contribute get up and um
shower and put my clothes on for
whatever
um but dude go towards that okay and
make sure you're modeling for your kids
make sure you're modeling hey man every
single one of us gets punched in the
mouth
hard here's what getting up looks like
here's what grieving it looks like
here's what being sad looks like
here's what gratitude looks like here's
what service looks like
and if you can't if kids are old enough
drag them along and make them mow the
yards with you
right just go for a walk in the evening
and pick up trash in your neighborhood
do it for an hour who cares
you're doing something to contribute
okay and it gets getting you out of your
head
here's the thing my brother you're not a
loser you're not yeah you got fired
sucks hate it hate it hate it hate it
but you're not a loser
no that's and that's i i know that and
again i said i'm pretty self-aware but
it kind of resonates because
i had another great job before and it's
a different profession but
ended up getting hurt and couldn't do it
anymore and i went down kind of that
that path and i could feel my mental
health going down
i'm not there because it was it was
different it was right after college it
was
i mean it was playing professional
football and now it's you know
and obviously you know about that
transitioning from professional athlete
to something else is hard and i kind of
got through it
got back to the top of another career
and i just feel myself going down that
that path again hey what do you want to
do man
i'm a football coach that's what i do
and i know i need to
not live in my career but that's that's
my purpose
you love coaching what ages college
you love coaching college ball right oh
yeah college ball is a zoo right now
right it is it's a bananas
could you call a local high school and
say hey i want to help out in spring
ball
and and i've i've gone down that path
it's just i don't want to commit to
something and then if a job comes up
hey not do it here you're going to do
that you're going to oh
you know you know yourself until you're
not going to get out of bed
you're right right so i want you to be
on the phone with a high school or a
middle school this week
okay and go let them know hey dude i got
canned from whatever university
and um i'm a good coach i'm searching
the country for it
and by the way when you're in when
you're a football coach you move a lot
and you also got a wife who's hanging on
now
that's right who can't commit to a
community or to a church or to her
friends because she's going to pack up a
move
and they live in that limbo i worked it
in university administration my wife
experienced the same thing and i didn't
realize it
that she was afraid the joke in our
house but it wasn't a joke was
planting asparagus she loves having a
big garden but those take two or three
years to come up
and she'd say i can't ever plant
asparagus because i never know we're
gonna live
and that broke my heart right and so
this year was the first year she
actually planted it since we've been
married
right so all to say is man go down there
and just start finding yourself get your
whistle out and get those
weird ridiculous coaching shorts out and
and go get involved in the lives of
young people get back out there
and the calls will come man you know
that
yeah hoping so stop
maybe you'll maybe you'll find out you
love coaching high school ball
i coached high school it's awesome
probably not but
dude you got to go do you know this
right yeah
yeah do i have your word you're going to
go make some calls today
yes sir excellent excellent man
and get out there and go volunteer help
out with them whether it's in the weight
room whether that's whatever
go make it happen and then dude get on
the phone and start calling some folks
i know that especially the college
coaching world man
it is about your friends and who you
know and your brothers and your sisters
and go make that stuff happen
right and if you've ever
thought about transitioning out of
coaching into doing something else or
transitioning to high school instead of
college
now is the time what do you want to do
college coaching is going to look super
different in the next few years
especially if ut and ou blow up the big
12 and then the domino
oh it's going to be a mess it's going to
be awesome it's going to be a mess
and they can pay players the whole
landscape is shifting if you've ever
thought man maybe uh
now's that time right but you gotta get
gotta get out of your head go serve go
be with
go do right go go do but i want you to
first have a funeral with your wife
more in this job let this thing exhale
tell her you're sorry for
taking her all over the country and now
she's just in that limbo land
and then get after it hey man thanks for
the call dude i'm grateful that you
trusted me with that
don't on we talk he got fired he got
fired i got fired
dude that's the loss of a loved one it
hurts and it hurts
bad all right man thank john thank you
so much for that call dude
you're awesome go do you got it
you got it all right hey james kelly
something rad i'm pulling out this
secret
beta deck of cards you finally got into
magic the gathering
i'm into magic to get i don't know what
that means
um that's why you sprinkle dust all over
the studio whenever i'm
magic the gathering all right so ready
here it goes
i'm just pulling a random one kelly
tell me america
tell me about a lie you got away with
sounds like about to incriminate myself
i'm so excited about this
um tell me about that you got away with
yeah so in high school my mother knew
everything i did i mean i got away with
nothing but one time we had a bunch of
my girlfriends we all told our parents
we were all spending the night with each
other
and then we was my senior year and we
got a
motel room like at red roof in or
whatever and had a party
but it was so bad because the entire
night i was terrified
that my mother was about to pull up
outside but i asked her not to you know
a few years later she was like no
amazingly i did not know about that
but i really didn't have any fun anyway
because i was so terrified she was gonna
find out
and i was gonna get killed
that's the lie yeah man
what a softball but thank you for
sharing wouldn't
tell you anything incriminating what's a
lie you got away with
i really can't think of one i got away
with but i can think of a
one that i super got busted for uh in
in fourth grade we had to get our
parents to sign
like every day that we did our homework
or something and i didn't do mine so
last minute i tried to forge my mom's
signature as a fourth grader
nailed it and somehow my teacher didn't
didn't buy it and i got in big trouble
for forgery so for for for now small for
into writing fraudulent checks and it's
been downhill ever since
so yeah same thing happened to me in
fourth grade except i got caught because
i misspelled my mom's name
so you're a forgery a forger and an
honor student right oh yeah
congratulations gt all day baby
um all right uh one more real quick oh
yes kelly what's your favorite rap lyric
go she's dressed in yellow she says
hello come sit next to me you find
fellow
run over there without a second to lose
hey what comes next hey bust a move
there you go james
man i'm gonna need to think about this
one
wow nick because you can and you won't
you don't stop
oh my gosh you can and you won't and you
don't stop
all right so guys listen this is so rad
we got cory back there za
so i've been hearing over and over and
over this one sentiment all right
deloney we turned off all our
electronics we got all the kids in the
room
now what do we do or all right dylan i
went to like make friends and i invited
a bunch of dudes out we all went to hang
out or
we got a couple of couples together and
we all went out
and then we just like looked at each
other we talked about work and then like
about our kids we don't have kids or
we're doodle parents
not a thing not a thing
i'm a i'm a cat dad nope you're not not
you're not
not a thing i'm a dog mom
nope not real not
real so
people were writing and saying what do
we do now
and i realized man it's just a new skill
we're gonna have to pick up
so we created these
conversation starters but they're
dilonified right so they're not just
like um
what's your hopes and dreams but there
what are your favorite rap lyric
when's the last time you cried um
if i took you to a tattoo parlor right
now kelly what tattoo would you get go
my favorite quote um a smooth sea never
made a skilled sailor
oh i thought it was gonna be stop
collaborate and listen you're gonna get
that on your forearm that would've been
dope
i've got a good one for this it's super
super nerdy though i would get a
tesseract or a hypercube which is a
two-dimensional your glasses are falling
down push them back
two-dimensional representation of a
four-dimensional
cube it's super cool is that how you can
play
magic games i've never played magic i've
never played it
so listen uh we set up a digital version
of this so you can get these for free
these are
we're coming out with conversation
starters it's going to be for like
like adults like to you can take them to
dinner man and what we're hearing back
from the folks that we've baited in
internally in the company we've got a
thousand people that work here
is they get through like two or three
cards in an hour or two hours they just
start
it starts conversations it's so fun it's
so good um
even my wife gives about seven
boxes of farts of what i do here but she
even i brought him
on our vacation we played these cards it
was fun with our we
went on vacation with some friends it's
awesome we're also going to create um
a deck of cards for parents and their
kids so you can
conversation starters for your kids
we're gonna have conversation cards
we're gonna call it deloney after dark
where you can talk about sex and
intimacy with your partner
in ways that it's gonna like just and
it's gonna help you get into some of
those conversations that are otherwise
gonna be awkward and then we may even
have one
for parents talk to parents about kids
just those conversations you don't know
right like what time is bedtime do you
spank your kids do you not why
what do you think about um your kid
having 17 google logins just to be a
third grader in a public school
all those things we're going to create
cards for those we're just trying to
give you
guys some tips and some conversation
starters on how to be human against
human 101 right it's how to be people
right so if you text conversation the
word conversation
c-o-n-v-e-r-s-a-t-i-o inch conversation
to
3-3-7-8-9-3-3-7-8-9-9-9-9-9-9-9-9-9-9-9-9-9-9
is going to send you to a site
it's going to give you 20 of these for
free print them off or they're going to
be on your phone
and then use them when you go to hang
out with your buddies or i just i
several times on today's show on the
last few shows i've told to people
go get some friends go start friends
make it awkward
take these with you and say hey dude
some hack on a radio i got these got
these questions these digital questions
and um so we're going to do this what's
your
hey zach you're back there what's your
favorite z uh what's your favorite uh
rap lyric
what's your favorite rap lyric i don't
listen i don't listen
i don't listen to rap here's a fun game
it's called get out of the studio
unbelievable i don't know how you got in
there
this is ridiculous so hey conversation
starters
text conversation to three three seven
eight nine
and dude we're giving you lo-fi tools to
change your relationships
and man once you start changing your
relationships you start making
relationships
then you're into uh
fixing anxiety fixing depression fixing
ptsd fixing all these things have been
hanging around for so long and just
melting people from inside out
conversation 33789 and as we wrap up
today's show
zach here's one of the greatest rap
songs ever written
pay attention by hey this band gets no
love
i guess this rap group epmd
one of the o g i mean one of the great
epmd and the song is awesome isn't that
some type of obscure therapy
emdr ah okay
it's cool to have producers that
actually listen to the show so close
so close em
emf that's a radiation i think you get
from
use a lot of acronyms so it sounded
familiar you're an acronym
was that a thing i don't know that's a
thing uh anyway
epmd off the 1988 strictly business out
strictly business record and the song is
you gots to chill and it goes like this
i love these guys relax your mind let
your conscience be free and get down to
the sounds of epmd
well you should keep quiet while the mc
rap but if you're tired zach then go
take a nap
you're asleep back there right now or
stay awake and watch the show i take
cause right now i'm about to shake and
break
the e-r-i-c-k is my name and i spell
thanks to the clientele yo i
rock well i'm not an mc who talking all
that junk
about who can beat who sounding like a
punk i just get down and i go for mine
say check one two and run down the line
to the average mc i'm known as the
terminator funky beat maker new jack
exterminator
you gots to chill oh my gosh what a
great song
this has been the dr john dolone's show